thank you thanks Andy for the
introduction and thanks for inviting ya
so today we're going to talk about my
attempt at building a superscalar
out-of-order processor
Burnett no it's it's really I wanted to
build a processor and the FPGA is kind
of an excuse to do so so first of all
myself so I'm currently a CP Architect
at Intel in Hillsboro I started there
about a year ago and I did my PhD at the
University of Toronto before that so
today's talk is going to be about the
work done at U of T during my PhD so
this I'm going to split this talk into
basically two major parts I'm going to
first start with some motivation you
know why we want to build this processor
why I chose x86 and then go through you
know just the high-level overview of
what I did and what the final results
were and then I'm going to jump into a
second part of the talk that goes into
more details about the actual like
architectural decisions how the
microarchitecture of the processor
actually looks so I'm gonna split up
into two of the two sections all right
so let's I'm I'm assuming most people
here know what an FPGA is already but
just in case I'm going to give a very
brief overview of the way ICD in a Fiji
so when FPGA is a digital circuit like
all in the digital circuits it is
basically a collection of logic gates
coked-up with why the nice thing about
FPGA is is that they are field
programmable which means you don't have
to fabricate them in the factory the
circuit actually doesn't get written
until powerup so how do they do that
they basically prefabricate everything
you will ever need on the chip and then
put in a bunch of switches and then
you'd get to choose what to connect but
at the end of the day it is still it
gates and wires you just choose whether
to use a wire or not instead of choosing
whether to put the wire on the chip or
not as you'd imagine prefabricating
everything has a pretty big cost so a
PGA's for an equivalent circuit is
somewhere around 20 times bigger and 20
times slower than a highly-tuned custom
circuit built directly on silicon
another inch so if you look at the
diagram you know the left I have you
know what you wanted to build is it
logic gates and a few wires on an FPGA
you prefabricate all the wires with
whole bunch of switches and now you have
to pack your circuit on to that FPGA
being constrained to whatever the
resources the FPGA gives you so wires
are prefabricated there are switches the
logic gates are somewhat more
coarse-grained they use lookup tables
which is basically a truth table so now
instead of having an Gates or gates you
have this flexible logic gate that can
become any logic function of a certain
number of inputs six inputs being very
common so on modern FPGA is typically
it's six in so from the perspective of
how you design things for the FPGA one
it's slower - you now have to be careful
about whether your circuit to the coarse
grained look-up tables that they if they
don't your circuit will still work it's
just less efficient so you don't have as
quite as much flexibility as if you had
a broad piece of silicon okay so an FPGA
is a circuit it can build anything that
includes processors and may not always
be the most appropriate but it's able to
do it so what do people use FPGAs for
usually they don't use it to build a
processor and they usually have a big
digital system you know data paths other
things but they often do still want a
processor to do control logic or
something like that something that's
flexible and not easily put into a block
of hardware so mainly for laziness so
that means you might want a processor as
part of an FPGA as the entire FPGA and
sometimes that would be a soft processor
so if you need more performance on an
FPGA the classical way of doing things
would be okay I'm going to build more
custom hardware make my system go faster
um but if you really have to be lazy if
we made the processor go faster you
could get an improvement in system
performance without or with going
through less effort
and designing custom logic you might be
able to get away with less of this logic
if your processor was magically faster
so that's the motivation for why we
might want a faster soft processor
all right so a few GA vendors actually
provides some fairly well optimized soft
processors but currently they tend to be
small in order single-issue
pipelines so you know they they are
small but they also tend to be very
fairly well optimized so they actually
run at fairly high clock rate for an
FPGA circuit so at the bottom I have
some other examples of soft processors
that weren't from the FPGA vendors and
the general trend you see is that those
that weren't highly tuned tend to have a
fairly low clock rate and you know
regardless of what microarchitecture you
use if you're giving up 50% of your
clock rate you're not really going to be
competitive so they do yes they
certainly do so that's a separate topic
and it is a I would say it is a
competitor to soft processors so if you
have a hard processor you may be less
willing to use a soft processor
okay so um let's suppose you do want a
faster softcore Scizor given that the
vendor provided processors are already
very fast in clock speed the only way
you're going to get more performance out
of it is to get parallelism you're not
really going to be able to improve on
the clock speed so there are many ways
of getting parallelism thread and data
level parallelism have been tried in
soft cursors before but I like
instruction level parallelism because
the user doesn't have to do anything it
just magically works but on the other
side the processor designer has to spend
a lot more effort than on the other two
styles of parallelism so I'm going to go
down the instruction level parallelism
root so the challenge for me is can I
design a microarchitecture and the
circuit the FPGA circuit to implement
that microarchitecture so that I can get
a significantly higher number of
instructions per cycle without it's
significant decrease in clock speed so
that I get an overall in performance
improvement at an affordable hardware
cost and without getting the user to
rewrite their software so I believe the
answer is yes and if you look back in
history the first out of order
hard processors typically got somewhere
about 50 percent improvement in IPC with
basically no change in frequency so this
is the first out of order versus the
previous generation so you know I'm
hoping I can get this on in FPGA as well
so now if we're going to build a
processor well let's first decide on an
instruction set so you already know the
answer I decided to do x86 but now why
wouldn't you want to do an x86 the most
obvious reason is some of these x86
features are really hard to implement
variable length instructions need length
decoding and x86 encoding is really hard
to find out the length of the
instruction so you know it's doubly bad
self-modifying code is surprisingly hard
to get correct there are a few
instructions that have to destination
operands and just make things
complicated but as it turns out when
you're building a processor for
high-performance turns out most of the
really hard features actually aren't x86
specific
so another problem with using an
existing instruction set is that if you
happened to come across a feature you
don't like you don't have the option of
saying will change software to work
around it
so one example that I suffered through
was the floating-point unit I didn't
want to build a floating-point unit but
I also couldn't change the existing
operating systems to get them to emulate
the floating-point so that means I have
to design in a emulation system that was
completely transparent from the
operating system that was very painful
so this isn't quite x86 it's when you
can't change the instruction set there's
some pain you're going to have to go
through of course a lot of people not
too far from here are going to be asking
why not just five it didn't exist when I
started this project that's my excuse
but I also question whether risk is even
the right design even if you had to
start over I'm not really going to talk
about at this point in this presentation
but you know I have some thoughts on it
okay so why would you want to implement
x86 my answer is it's very easy to
implement not the hardware but compared
to implementing all of the software that
goes along with it so I found a quote
from when the risk five people is saying
that they were suffering through a lot
of pain trying to get benchmarks and I
was like I will just use the rebuild by
anyways because it works so you know
there's a lot of legacy software out
there benchmarks operating systems you
know web browsers are really complex
pieces of software then our instructions
that's specific because of the
JavaScript chid so these are really
really hard to port to a different
instruction set
there's even software and some really
unexpected places like your VGA card
BIOS the alpha systems actually has to
do x86 emulation just to be able to use
commodity graphics cards because there's
a little bit of x86 software in the
firmware so it's really the software
legacy that motivates x86 and you know
even after going through all of this you
know I still can't do any of this large
software thing I can implement x86 which
is easier than implementing any other
software my opinion okay so if we're
gonna build stuff versus here so we've
decided we're going to build ass off for
us to say this is the goals that I set
out to achieve I wanted to build a to
issue out of order processor just so I
could call that superscalar I wanted
good improvement in IPC so and when did
that say let's aim for 2x what Altera's
single-issue in order software so I
could do let's try and improve a little
bit on the frequency but I didn't
actually managed to achieve that so
that's a goal that was not achieved I
also I chose the x86 instruction set and
made sure that I didn't have to rewrite
any of the software so it should be
binary compatible with all the existing
operating systems and programs and so on
including system mode so I ended up
actually testing with 16 different
operating systems and a whole bunch of
user level of benchmarks right so I was
targeting the p6 instruction set Pentium
Pro 64-bit is another huge block of the
instruction set because it requires all
the vector extensions and so on 32-bit
for now okay so um all right so let's
design the processor so the first thing
you want to do is I'm building a
processor for an FPGA there is a whole
bunch of literature on how you're
supposed to build processors how is an
FPGA different from what everyone else
is doing you know if the FPGA looks
exactly the same as regular silicon well
we'll just build the same processor and
call it a day so let's start with
looking at how FPGAs are actually
different from custom logic on silicon
so this is a study where I compared
basically it's basically literature
literature search on published papers
and custom silicon versus what I can
build on that VGA and I compared the
area and
delay clock speed of various circuit
parts and also of some open-source
processors that have commercial
implementations so if you compared whole
processors I think I compared the köppen
SPARC there was a Pentium that was also
synthesized and in the PGA so on average
all processors are about 22 times bigger
and 22 times slower when synthesized for
an FPGA than their original custom
commercial implementation so if it's
just bigger and slower that doesn't tell
you how you might need to adapt your
design to fit the FPGA so I broke that
down into let's take some common circuit
styles and see which ones are
particularly bad and which ones are
particularly good and that might
influence what I might want to design so
it turns out that for the various
circuit types the delay didn't really
vary that much FPGAs were slower but you
know more or less uniformly slower
except for SRAM des armes were
particularly a little bit faster but the
big difference was in area so things
like random logic multiplexers were
particularly inefficient multi ported
memories were inefficient cams but
circuits that have hard block support on
FPGA so FPGAs have hard RAM blocks they
have hard adder carry chains the
circuits that use these blocks tend to
be particularly area efficient so my
conclusion just from looking at this is
at a high level because the delay
variation wasn't all that big my my
conclusion was you can probably get away
with a fairly conventional process or
microarchitecture you just have to be a
little bit careful to avoid or reduce
the size of the expensive components and
use a little bit more of the cheaper
components so that made a few influenced
a few micro architectural decisions for
example it was decided to use a physical
register file instead of a reorder
buffer that stored data with reservation
stations
oh sorry are you talking about area
until they are we talking about the area
today no no these three are high but
these three are low so multiplexer is
multi ported Rams and cams are very high
in area the red buys this this is 2.2 22
in the middle yes oh yeah it's a log
type factors of 10 22 in the middle okay
so it was decided to use this physical
intro file instead of storing the data
in the in the reservation stations
because that keeps the data in grams
rather than in a cam so that's more
efficient it also makes more sense to
have low associative low associativity
caches because that requires rams rather
than a big cam so you know the cost of
cams influences some of the mic
architectural decisions both like all of
these choices have been used
successfully in commercial processors
but I think on an FPGA certain choices
are more preferred so these aren't
particularly strange decisions they're
also used in commercial processors okay
so now that we know how the fpd is
different let's start designing the
processor so this is the methodology I
followed when I just designed the
processor so I started off with a
functional simulator box are all of you
familiar with box roughly it's an open
source x86 functional simulator so again
because it's x86 I can use this as a
golden reference model and I didn't have
to read it myself
so I
so I started off with a functional
simulator I then went and replaced the
CPUs model inside the simulator with a
detailed timing model and functional so
replace the entire CPU and now it has
timing models so I know how fast it goes
but it continues to use the simulation
of display disks everything else around
the system so I was focusing just on the
processor and the detailed CPU model was
informed by the FPGA architecture that I
just talked about and then I took
another copy of box rendered in parallel
and now use this as verification as the
golden reference model so now my
functional model functional and timing
model needs to retire the same
instructions with the same results as
the functional reference model so I run
a whole bunch of workloads boot a whole
bunch of OSS in parallel and I compare
the results and I make sure my
microarchitecture actually produces the
correct results and when I'm satisfied
with that I will then take the detailed
model and start building circuits based
on the microarchitecture that I came up
with so final answer the microprocessor
that I ended up with is a fairly typical
x86 pipeline so you know it starts with
instruction fetch it fetches eight
instruction bytes per cycle it doesn't
know what the instructions are just
fetches eight bytes then it goes through
a whole bunch of lengths decode stages
that tries to figure out where the
instructions start and split them up
into the instructions in this case there
are three instructions in this eight
byte block it then sends chops up the
bytes and sends them to decoders each
decoder handles each instruction and now
you can do them in parallel and the
decoder decodes the instructions until
my crops the micro ops are then go
through two fairly typical register
rename or it just replaces all of the
logical register numbers with physical
register numbers and now it goes through
a scheduler which schedules instructions
based on whether the operands are
available
and then after they execute the
instructions are committed in program
order so it's you know very very
classical x86 pipeline yes so you you
can't avoid it but there are things like
I will try and reduce the size I will
not put the data in the cam they are
there I I have seen some papers where
you avoid it but you pay an IPC and it's
also really hard to design and you know
not quite worth the effort okay so you
know the summary of all is going through
all of this is that the main challenge
of every single stage was you know let's
trade the circuit complexity and delay
in size with various other things and in
the front end it's mainly I need to
support the common case fast without
spending too much hardware to support
all the corner cases the scheduler its
trading off circuit complexity with
capacity execution units is trading it
off with latency so it all boils down to
you know how fast can you make your
circuits go you can come up with an
architecture but you have to spend a lot
of effort making these circuits fast so
later on in you'll see a lot of effort
on the circuit design then the second
half of the talk
I didn't try too hard to reduce the area
but the end result is it's you know like
7% of a 40 nanometer FPGA it's like 1%
of 1 now it's tiny so yeah so so I just
got to the result slide where I will be
talking about this so here is the final
result so I didn't quite get the
processor to finished so you know it's
it's a collection of parts and some
projections on what I think the final
processor would probably take up so this
is a caveat these numbers are not take
these with a grain of salt so at the end
the all this area adds up to something
like twenty twenty-nine thousand LMS
which is Altera's logic unit if you
compare it to Altera's processor
configured with you know fairly large
caches and so on you know typical what
you might want from a higher end version
of the Altera just to make my number not
look so bad it's just like six or seven
times bigger an area and about 20
percent slower in clock speed but
because the existing software sisters
are so tiny it is really only you know
seven percent of a statics for which is
I think three generations back at this
point where we're at statics 10 right
now and I think it's about one and a
half percent of a strat extend 64 bits
or 64 bits x86 I I expected as much much
bigger next it's not the 64 bit that's
big 64 bit would double your data path
and so on but 64 bit also requires 128
bit vector operation yes and a whole
bunch of floating-point stuff so I
expected much bigger
I would say somewhere about you know
five to ten times there's there's also a
bunch of like architecture decisions
that won't work in x86 in 64-bit for
example I tuned my front-end to decode
say up to one prefix byte and assumed
you know most instructions were about
three or four bytes long and eight bytes
and longer were very rare but 64-bit
adds more prefix bytes to the beginning
so I would have to redesign the decoder
to handle you know one prefect to prefix
bytes is now a common case instead of a
rare case so there's a whole bunch of
other things that you would have to
change yes I think it would very easily
fit but I think my main concern is how
much clock speed are you giving up
because I when I was designing this I
was actually focusing much more on clock
speed than area because I think clock
speed is much harder to get and we have
a lot of area so if the area is not the
constrained resource here so I don't
have a good estimate of how fast you can
clock a 64-bit version of this or what
kind of changes you might need to
various places to make it work alright
so area is seven times bigger but still
small frequency it is currently limited
by the memory system memory system was
the most painful thing to design in this
processor but it is currently the F max
limit but I think it should be fairly
straightforward to repipe line this to
get to a trade more clock speed for an
extra cycle of l1 hit latency so it is
possible to get more frequency here also
interesting is that the stuff you would
normally associate with out of order
they register rename or in the scheduler
those are actually the fastest units
that I had so if you're thinking of
building a out of order an on x86
processor this kind of suggests to you
that maybe it's not such a bad idea so
we're losing an area we're losing on
see I'm hoping to gain on IPC so here is
a plot of specint mm only those
components that don't use much
floating-point because I didn't have a
floating-point unit so this is just the
integer portion of the spec int I so in
yellow is the IPC or the per clock
performance I had to normalize have to
per clock performance because there's me
off and there's arm here so IPC doesn't
work all right there are three different
instruction sets in here so in yellow is
I'm making everything relative to my
processor and well first thing is the
reason I have so many processors to
compare to here is because all of them
are x86 and I could just copy the
binaries and run them it took very
little effort if these are all so so the
nias data point and the arm data point
took much more effort to get because I
had to port the benchmarks over so this
is another advantage of using a popular
and existing instruction set there was a
paper on synthesizing the atom but that
was after the fact
so it wasn't prototype to is they built
the atom they've released it and then
okay we'll take the RTL and we'll try
and fit it on our FPGA
not that part I didn't know it
so I'm only aware of the published paper
on a demand that was an after-the-fact
okay so in this chart I also listed the
clock speed of the processors because
this is per clock performance I only
list that the clock speed so to give you
an idea of what the expected memory
latency would be so for example a
processor with the native clock speed of
100 megahertz sees a very different
memory latency than a processor at 3
gigahertz so given all these processors
I chose 3 interesting comparison points
the first comparison point is with nias
that's our you know that's our stated
competitor here let's compare to the
existing soft processor we're getting
fairly good improvement in per clock
performance about 2.7 X and if you
multiply that with the loss in frequency
we're still more than 2 times faster
than in the US another interesting
comparison point is the Pentium Pro
because it turns out at the high level
of Pentium Pro actually looks a lot like
the processor I'm designing it's also
Pentium Pro is three wide mine is too
wide it has basically the same cache
size is 8 K 256 K I chose the same cache
sizes as well and the IPC is actually
not too far not not too different so and
then another interesting design point is
the more recent atom out-of-order
silvermont I think it's the first out of
order atom and I get basically the same
IPC but i think the atom is actually a
better microarchitecture than mine
because it is seeing a much higher
memory latency so it has much bigger
caches and it has to deal with hundreds
of clocks of memory latency instead of
20 or 30 but the end result is the IPC
looks pretty much the same so you know I
think I can conclude that you know by
microarchitecture my microarchitecture
design wasn't all too bad it's
reasonable compared to the Intel mic
architecture and it's a fairly big gain
of over neo so I think I will declare
success here
all right so here's the summary of the
first part of the tuck so I designed a
micro architecture and a bunch of
circuits for another water processor it
supports both system and user modes it's
much bigger than an EOS but it's also
actually pretty small relative to an
FPGA because FPGA is keep growing
exponentially and the us really hasn't
changed in 20 years and it does get a
significant performance boost so I think
I'm demonstrating that out-of-order can
work on FPGA and even x86 is feasible I
did not look at power consumption at all
so FF max is my primary design Google
and I just observed area alright so in
the second part of the talk I'm
basically going to go through the
processor pipeline from fetch down to
commit and talk about the what I think
are the interesting designs at each
stage something to keep in mind is that
my timing budget is basically five logic
levels which is about 3 and 1/2
milliseconds so so you'll see that a lot
of the circuit designs were very
carefully designed to try not to exceed
4 or 5 logic levels just to hit my
frequency target and a lot of the
circuits were designed bottom up instead
of top down so I started with little
building blocks and tried to make them
bigger instead of let's use this giant
piece of RTL let's synthesized it - ok
so let's start with it at the beginning
so the front end of the processor use
instruction fetch and decode in 32-bit
x86 code on the benchmarks I ran on it
the average instruction links is about
3.4 bytes so if I wanted to sustain 2
instructions per cycle
I think fetching 8 per cycle is probably
good enough so I decided on fetching
eight bytes per cycle
x86 is really annoying in that you don't
really know the instruction link until
you've read the instruction and x86 has
these things called prefix bytes where
you have an instruction but you can add
bytes before the instruction to change
the meaning of the instruction so there
is if you just follow this rule there is
actually no limit to the length of an
x86 instruction because you're allowed
to have repeated prefixes there is a
rule that says if you exceed 15 15 bytes
it's just considered wrong but other
than that there is no length limit so
you you have to conceptually you have to
sequentially scan through every byte of
the instruction to find out all the
prefixes before you figure out the
length of the instruction and width and
then you can start reading the next
instruction so it's really hard to
parallel eyes instruction decode if you
don't know the instruction length so the
observation here is that on 32-bit x86
code eighty-six percent of instructions
have no prefix bytes and fourteen
percent have one prefix bytes and almost
no instructions have more prefix place
SS I've seen seven prefix bytes but it
is extremely rare so that means that I
chose to design the decoder so that it
would be able to handle up to one prefix
byte with no penalty so that means it's
really looking at two cases there is
either no prefix byte or one prefix play
will handle both cases in parallel if it
satisfies this it can decode two
instructions per cycle there's a penalty
if you exceed the number of free fixed
bytes but it still must handle this
correctly so it sequentially scans
through the prefix bytes if you exceed
one prefix but if you won't go 64 bits
this will have to change because the
number of prefix bytes actually goes up
a lot so three becomes fairly common
either or to prefix points becomes
fairly common
next stage once you decode the
instructions you have to decode them
into microwaves in my particular design
my my crafts were actually fairly
powerful in that they both contained a
operation arithmetic operation and a
memory operation so they looked a lot
like regular eyes x86 instructions they
don't look like risk instructions so as
a result the number of micro ops is
actually very small near ninety four
percent of the time one instruction maps
to one microwave so this handles all of
the register memory addressing modes in
a single microbe they are scheduled and
executed separately but they are treated
as one microbe in the front end and more
than one my carp is quite rare so you
know we'll put a cap of your will this
will be able to sustain the full decode
throughput if your instruction decode
into two or fewer microbes there's a
penalty if you exceed that
so next 86 the worst case is pretty
difficult to deal with but the common
case is actually quite straightforward
okay so now that we have micro ops the
next stage is register renaming so
register renaming takes all of the
logical register numbers so in x86
there's things like EAX EBX ECX and maps
them to the physical register number
that's actually on the in the
microarchitecture so it turns out we
have to map a lot of registers per clock
in the worst case a instruction can have
seven registers referenced so that means
I have to rename 14 source operands per
clock so that's not just general purpose
registers so because there's a memory
operation there are there's arithmetic
which takes some sources the address can
take some sources there's also
segmentation in x86 so you have to
rename that as well there's condition
codes in x86 so that's yet another news
source so it comes up to a lot of
sources but you can pretty much do them
all in parallel
so another interesting design here is
that I decided to have to give each
execution unit its own physical register
file so this is not a centralized
register file the reason is if you
remember way back earlier multi ported
Rams are very expensive its multi ported
write ports that were very expensive
so in this design if each arithmetic
unit has its own register file each
register file only needs one write port
because it can only be written by that
execution unit but now the trade off is
you your registry name room now has to
track which register file is my operand
in and it also makes it's also somewhat
unbalanced in that if you execute a lot
of operations on one execution unit then
all the operands end up being in that
register file leaving the other register
files underutilized so the trade-off
here is you save multi ported Rams in
exchange for wasting register file
capacity but cam's multi ported Rams are
expensive but single photographs are
cheap on an FPGA so this is a good
trade-off here and the way we do this is
by hacking the register rename where to
track where the operands are
so this is the renamer circuit I ended
up with its pipelined over two stages
the first stage basically checks all the
dependencies between the two yeah my
crops being renamed in that clock cycle
and that decides all of the MUX select
signals and in the second stage is just
a whole pile of muxes so what else do I
have to say here it's fairly fast it's
not all that big x86 actually makes the
register rename are easier to design
because it has so few registers so
there's only 8 general-purpose registers
I think it expanded it to 11 including
temporaries so it was cheap enough that
I could make the entire register rename
her out of lookup tables I didn't have
to go through make a SRAM block to store
the renaming table so if I had to do
this on a RISC like architecture with 32
registers the rename it would actually
be much more expensive so after renaming
the microbes get sent to an instruction
scheduler so the instruction scheduler
stores all of the operands and tracks
whether the operands are ready so all
it's doing is saying it will pick the
earliest ready instruction and send it
off for execution once it's executed
it'll track that the destination has
been produced and some new instructions
might become buddies
so this is just tracking the data flow
of the instructions that are in the
scheduler and it just keeps doing that
repeatedly so scheduler size traded with
circuit cost the scheduler size affects
how much parallelism you can extract if
you have a large scheduler you can look
further ahead in the instruction stream
and that gets you more instructions per
cycle so here is a plot of achieved
instructions per cycle versus the size
of the scheduler and I was kind of
greedy and I chose to use a 32 by 32
scheduler although you might say now you
could probably get away with 24 without
giving up too much performance
so we're training off capacity for F max
an area here and 32 gets me 275
megahertz so that's good enough so I'm
going to take that
so the scheduler circuit looks like this
it's a four-way distributed matrix
scheduler so four-way distributed means
there are four execution units in my
processor each person each execution
unit has its own slice of the scheduler
which means my crops that are executed
on a particular execution unit must go
in that scheduler so that means that
it's more easily to get imbalance in the
scheduler in a unified scheduler which I
think Intel likes to use all my crops go
into the same pool so it's less likely
to overflow but the trade-off is that
with distributed schedulers each slice
of the scheduler smaller so you can make
it faster but you get less efficient
utilization of the entries so I decided
with four-way distributed it's a matrix
scheduler so matrix schedulers are kind
of interesting they matrix schedules so
normally when you think of a scheduler
you think of a micro op and it has
operands and you check whether the
operands are ready or not you will
compare tags when you execute an
instruction you broadcast the tag and
the tag says this operand operand number
3 is now ready a matrix scheduler
doesn't track operands it actually
tracks dependencies between instructions
directly so instead of storing this
instruction requires operands 3 and 5 it
says this instruction is dependent on
previous instructions number 6 and 8 so
it tracks whether the instruction is
completed rather than whether the
operand is available and that it's a
matrix because if you draw it out the
circuit it actually looks like a grid of
wires with a single flip-flop and a NAND
gate at each intersection point so
matrix schedulers are faster when
they're small but they grow
quadratically in
sighs they're basically in big matrix so
for smaller schedulers matrix schedulers
are faster so at 32 entries that still
consider small so I went the matrix
route if the scheduler were to grow
significantly I might choose to go back
to the more traditional camera because
it scales better so I chose 32
instructions that's I chose the size 32
scheduler for comparison the Pentium Pro
at 20 and skylake which is fairly recent
Intel processor is 97 so it gives you an
idea of roughly where where my design
sits all right so we're going to look a
little bit more closely at the one of
the picker circuits for scheduling okay
so the purpose of the picker circuit the
job is I have a bunch of instructions my
co-ops some of them are ready to be
executed this circuits job is simply to
pick the first one that's ready and send
it off for execution unit it's a very
simple circuit so you know in this
diagram I have a bunch of zeros and ones
ones means ready and the output of this
circuit is I just want the earliest one
that's all it has to do
turns out this circuits actually kind of
slow in an FPGA because FPGA don't have
really wide logic gates and it can only
do six inputs so the circuit that I came
up with is based on some past work on
adders it's a prefix tree that's
logarithmic in depth so
I forgot how to explain this anyway if
Callahan Carlson prefix tree it's used
in adders the end result is basically at
this structure instead of being linear
in delay it becomes logarithmic and
delay because it's an FPGA with six
input look-up tables I chose to use a
radix six prefix tree I think most if
you'd built this on silicon most people
choose radix two so FP is a little
special because six is not really more
expensive than two and one
difficult thing that I encountered was
the logic synthesizer actually wants to
tear up my radix six tree and make it
linear again so I had to spend a lot of
a hurt fighting with the synthesis tool
yes yes it's it's linear uses less area
so I think it was doing something like
that common sub-expression elimination
it often makes things slower
okay so after scheduling the microbes
that executed my processor has three
different execution units the aju is for
memory operations that computes the
addresses there's a simple ALU and
shifter that executes in single cycle
and only for the simple instructions and
then there's a longer three cycle
execution unit for all the other things
I couldn't fit in a single cycle so I
think the single cycle ALU is probably
the most interesting from a circuit
perspective so we're gonna look more
closely at that so the single cycle ALU
is actually composed of three separate
parts there's a shifter there's an adder
and there's bitwise logic for things
like or and and and so on
good weiss so we're gonna look at the
shifter and the adder circuits so let's
start with the shifter so shifters on
FPGAs are rather inefficient as we saw
before multiplexers are inefficient on
the feejee a and the shifter is really
just a whole pile of multiplexers so we
have to spend a lot of effort to figure
out what's the most efficient way to
build a shifter so this is probably if
you had to shift a 32-bit operand this
is probably pretty close to optimal a6
input lookup table can implement a 4 to
1 multiplexer which means you need three
levels of logic in order to do a shift I
don't think you can improve on this so
what I did was starting off with that
data path I added a whole bunch of
control logic to make the shifter be
able to do left and right shift at three
different operand sizes and rotations
and a whole bunch of very other
variations like vite swap and sign
extension everything that looks kind of
like a shift and crammed it all into a
data path that was three levels of logic
except for a few small control pests so
the critical path was still on the three
a three logic levels
so as you can see the interesting part
is only if you look at the control side
on the left the control was designed
such that the first level of muxes have
zero levels of logic for the control and
there's more and more control for the
later levels of the data path so I
managed to pack a lot of different x86
specific shift operations into the basic
data path without really extending the
critical path by very much so the end
result here is that this particular
shifter circuit is 50 50 percent faster
and 46 percent smaller then if I simply
wrote the same operations in HDL and let
cordis synthesize whatever light so
basically you can quote a case statement
and say I need to do all of this alright
so now we're gonna look at the adder so
on an FPGA there are hard carry chains
for adders and it's really really hard
to improve on that unless your adders
are you know thousands of bits long so
the hard adder is pretty much you know
you can't improve on it it's basically
optimal for 32 bits but what we can
improve is x86 says we need to do an
addition but there's also a zero flag
and the zero flag says is the results
zero or not and on an FPGA you don't
have wide gates so a zero flag is
basically a nor gate with 32 inputs and
that requires three levels of logic so
now that we have is the zero flag
computation cost just as much as the
Attic but it's also in series with the
adder because you need the result so we
don't like that so it turns out that you
can actually compute whether the sum of
two numbers is equal to a constant
without using a carry chain and this was
done many many years ago using some
addressed caches and things like that so
this is an existing technique but hey we
can apply it here as well and now we can
compute the addition in parallel with
computing whether the addition is equal
to zero now in parallel instead of in
series so it's still three
levels but now they're in hello so this
circuit is you know 24 percent faster
it's not quite as impressive it's also
bigger because you now come the zero
flag computation is more complex but you
know it's 55 percent area increased but
it's really only 30 logic elements you
know out of 27,000 it's not much of a
price to pay I think so we're gaining
some speed okay next section now I'm
going to talk about the memory system so
the memory system is basically the whole
system that does loads and stores for
memory and from my experience this is
probably the single hardest component of
the processor I think I spent about two
years on this part alone it's kind of
ridiculous and it's not really x86
specific so memory operations are
basically loads and stores in next 86
this case we decode them into my crops
and my crops basically our loads in
storage so the designs basically the
same regardless of whether it's x86 or
risk its loads and stores so it's not
just a unit that goes to memory for
performance reasons we need caches and
there are a lot of caches there's data
caches there's instruction caches
there's also caches of a page table so
you know you end up with something like
two TLB eese - data caches and an l2
cache so you've got a whole bunch of
caches in the system so when you have
caches you have the very classical cache
trade-offs in this plot I show two of my
benchmarks dry stone on the Left specint
on the right I showed these two because
dry stone basically doesn't touch memory
at all so it's not very sensitive spec
in touch with memory a lot so these are
basically the two extremes just to show
you two types of extreme workloads what
happens when I play with the memory
system so very classic result is as you
increase the cache size your performance
improves dry stone doesn't touch memory
therefore it doesn't care so performance
doesn't change when you change the
sighs l1 caches have to be small because
we had we we have to be able to build
them so we ended up choosing a kilobytes
which is quite small and we're giving up
quite a bit of performance about using
something this small but it turns out
you can get most of this back by having
a no to cache so we also added an l2
cache and of course dry stone doesn't
care either but in addition to the very
classical just cache size trade-offs
there's when you do out of order there's
a whole bunch of other fancy things you
can do them to the memory system things
like how many concurrent misses can you
support if you are handling a cache miss
can you keep executing independent
instructions and execute more cache
misses in parallel so now you can get
memory level parallelism can your memory
system support out of order execution a
lot of earlier out of order processors
did not execute memory operations out of
order because it was very difficult to
track dependencies between memory
operations so yeah if you have a store
followed by a load is this load
dependent on the store it's hard to
figure that out
so it turns out for at least for my
processor these other techniques also
get you some fairly big performance
gains so I ended up choosing the far
right data point so my memory system is
out of order it also does memory
dependence speculations so it will
speculate whether loads are dependent on
stores and then flush the pipeline if
they were and I thought they went how
much time do you have okay we don't have
much time okay so here's a summary of
the l1 memory system the data side only
so we have data cache and tags we have a
TLB the MS HR is Miss status handling
register this is for tracking the
outstanding cache misses and then we
have a store queue for stores so the
critical path of this is whenever you do
a memory access for example load you
first have to do an address translation
and then after you get the translated
address you have to compare it to the
cache tags to see whether you've hit in
the l1 cache and then if it does you
have to select out which bytes of the
data you actually want to load so just
to remind you x86 does not require
aligned accesses so you do need a
rotator after the data array so one
optimization I did here was this is a
fairly long critical path if you
replicated some of the logic it turns
out this critical path can be made
shorter by pre computing you know both
so it's a two-way TLB so we pre compute
both answers assuming it hits in one way
or hit in the other and then we select
the correct answer of the elbe so this
is a trade-off of we spend more area in
order to decrease delay so I'm going to
skip over this this is the horrifying
version of the previous slide it goes
through all of the many ways a single
load could fail and how you handle it
okay
so this is the final circuit level
diagram of the same circuit I showed you
in the previous slide it's a very
complicated diagram and I don't think
it's clear exactly what you're looking
at so the important thing to notice here
is that the critical path is through the
TLB and translations it's four point
three nanoseconds it's interesting to
note that there are a lot of other
critical paths that are very close and
delay so this is a very highly optimized
and tuned circuit such that a whole
bunch of different paths have very
similar delay so the blue boxes are look
six input look-up tables so basically
all of this circuit was all hand map to
lookup tables and there was all designed
so that all of the critical paths go
through exactly five look-up tables
so the end result is that the whole
memory system is about 4.3 nanoseconds
and delay and she compared it to the
same memory stages on the Neos on the
Altera
soft processor then he actually have a
much simpler memory system and they take
longer they fix 6 nanoseconds to do the
translation and cache access but they
split it over one and a half cycles
whereas I pack it all into a single
cycle so I'm training a lot of hardware
for increased delay alright so we've
reached the end of the second part of my
talk so I'm concluding that out of order
processors are useful and feasible they
are big but they can get your
performance but only if you pay a lot of
attention to the circuit level design
and not give up 50% of your clock speed
so you can do that either by making
microarchitecture choices that suit the
substrate that you're building on or you
can spend a lot of effort designing
these circuits to implement your
microarchitecture and I found that level
design is actually often quite useful
but also painful because the logic
synthesizers are often undos your
optimizations so I unfortunately the
processor isn't actually finished so
it's still a collection of pieces right
now some pieces still missing I think
there's still some hope that the memory
system could be optimized for further
frequency by adding an extra cycle and
the fact that this processor was missing
a floating-point unit was extremely
painful so I certainly hope to add a
floating-point unit some time of any
performance level the emulation
mechanism for the FPU is much more
painful than actually having enough to
you that's that that's my conclusion
here alright so at the end of my talk
there are questions
you